- One quick thing, though.
Do I have your consent to play with you?
(grunts)
- Yes.
- And do you know what your safe word is?
- Mercy.
- Josh Groban.
- John Stamos.
- Denzel!
- Why, does that hurt?
- It doesn't hurt, I just don't like it.
- We haven't even gotten
to the actual contact.
(electronic dance music)
- I don't know anything about BDSM,
except I assume it's just a
lot of hitting each other?
- I always skip past it on Pornhub,
which I don't go to often, but--
- Wait wait wait, hold up!
- I picture it as like a guy with a zipper
that goes over his face.
- Yeah, I associate it
with weird porn stuff.
- I see you squeezin'
them cheeks together!
(grunts)
- The whole thing with BDSM
is that it's about consent.
The agreement that two people have made
that their both enjoying and
getting the most pleasure
out of the experience.
(screaming)
- This is your job.
- Yes.
- This is your profession.
- It is.
- What does BDSM stand for?
- Well, BDSM is bondage, discipline,
- Shut up!
- submission, domination,
and sadomasochism.
- Aww, fuck.
(laughs)
- Which one are you? (laughs)
- I guess we're gonna find out.
- We're gonna find out really fast,
but I'm supposed to be the dom today.
- Okay.
- So, you're gonna have to kind of follow.
Do you have bad knees or
any physical problems?
- Not yet.
What are misconceptions
you think people have
about BDSM in general?
- My assumption is that it's
usually during sex, right?
- So the line we don't cross
with professional BDSM is
we don't have sex.
- What about "Fifty Shades of Grey"?
- I read the first book
of "Fifty Shades of Grey".
Scandalized!
- Well, I read it with my wife.
- But it's very popular.
- So many people in America got turned on
by the same gross smut.
- Do you like it?
Is it accurate?
- What I love is that it's brought
the fetish/BDSM/kink community
up close and personal to the
what we call "vanilla" general public.
- And we are going to
read excerpts from it.
- "I turn, and he's
regarding me intently."
- "He reaches between my legs
and pulls on the blue string."
What?
"And gently takes my tampon out
"and tosses it into the nearby toilet."
Holy fuck!
- In a professional setting,
the limits of BDSM would be
no exchange of bodily fluids,
no penetration, no sex.
- "As he makes his way
around me, he flicks again,
"this time hitting my nipple.
"I throw my head back as
my nerve endings sing."
- "'Okay, and what do I get out of this?'
"He shrugs and looks almost apologetic.
"'Me.'"
- BDSM is not just about pain.
It actually can be very connected
and emotional and freeing.
- "'Oh, geez!' I can feel myself quicken."
- "'That's right, baby!'"
- "he rasps as he grinds into me."
(grunts)
- In your personal life,
if you're practicing BDSM,
- Sure.
- If it's consensual with you
and your partner, anything goes.
- I'm ready to be dominated in
a way that is both respectful
but also very dominate-y.
- [Allison] "'The feathery
thing has me intrigued.'
"I touch it, hesitantly.'"
- The feather can be nice
for the sensation play
to get the skin all activated.
- Here we go!
(Gabby screams)
Right in the pits!
- Okay, hold on!
- Yeah.
- How's that?
- Feels good.
- Ulch ulch ulch...
- This feels weird.
- [Zach] What does the blindfolding add?
- Well, if you're blindfolded,
you don't know what's coming.
- So tight.
I can't see anything.
- I'm ready to sleep on an airplane.
- Don't talk!
- I don't even need to
see you to dominate you.
Bam!
- And it heightens your sensitivity.
You're waiting for something to happen,
and when it happens, it's
that much more intense.
(screams)
(laughs)
- It's very freeing to just let go,
let someone else take over.
Handcuffs can do that for you.
- Here we go!
You're in trouble.
- It's like a traffic stop.
(rips Velcro)
- Huh? What?
- This isn't fun, it just seems like work.
- You definitely know you're
in the submissive role.
You definitely know that
someone else is in charge.
(flogger cracks)
- Oh, god.
- Now what?
Now what?
- "It's suede and like a
small cat o' nine tails
"but bushier.
"It's called a flogger."
(flogger cracks)
- Ah!
- Ow!
(laughing) Eugene!
- Quinta, I don't think
you understand the concept!
- Give me a boner with pain, Ned!
(flogger crack)
- Oh, f--
- The flogging's great
if it's not on the tummy.
(flogger cracks)
- Ow!
- Oh!
- "Swear to me!"
- I think in the book it was on the tummy,
which doesn't feel very good.
(flogger cracking)
- Oh, god!
God!
- Put your butt up, bitch!
(flogger cracks)
Bam!
- I guess it's okay.
(flogger cracking)
- God, Ned!
- That's my knee!
- What? That's a sexy place!
(flogger cracking)
- Move to another area! God!
(flogger cracks)
- It's not terrible.
- I kinda like it.
- Can I do it harder?
- Yeah.
- Do you want it harder?
- Eugene.
- I'm sorry. (laughs)
- I'm not turned on.
I'm not aroused.
- [Zach] What is the purpose of this?
- A lot of people love the feeling
of rope being pulled across their skin.
- I'm gonna tie your wrist.
- Yeah! Tie it!
- Shh!
- Tighter!
- So I'm getting spanked now.
- Mmm-hmm.
- Is there a difference in paddle types?
- Well, yes.
When you're learning to spank someone,
or you're going to be
spanked for the first time,
you wanna go with an over
the knee hand spanking.
- Are you ready?
- Yes!
- Do you feel safe?
- I feel safe.
- You shouldn't!
- Shu-pow!
- Spank it.
- Whap!
- Harder.
- Uh-oh, pancakes on your butt.
- Oh no-- Ow!
- Ooh!
- Okay.
- Ahh!
- Oh my gosh!
- Eugene!
- Ahh!
- Are you okay?
- Oh.
- Ah!
- Yeah!
- The worst paddle, in
my opinion, is wood.
- Ohhh!
- "He hits me again across the buttocks."
- Oh, thank you, Mistress,
may I have another?
I don't think I'll return
to all of these things.
Ohh!
But in a nice, safe setting,
I could see myself returning to a few.
- Safe, sane, and consensual;
that's what it's all about.
Was it safe today?
- Yes.
- Was it sane?
- (laughs) Mostly.
(violet wand buzzes)
- Ah!
- Ah! Ee-ii-hii!
- I did like the teasing aspect.
That was when it got weird,
'cause it got a little sexual.
- [Keith] It got a little bit sexy.
- Ah!
It was just a lot of really great...
- Hey! Shut it!
Shut your mouth!
Don't tell me what to do!
- Mmm! Mmm!
Mmm.
I don't think that you like to be sub...
- Eugene!
- The whole point is for you
not to know when it's coming.
- Well, I don't get this.
- We learned that Allison hits
much harder than I anticipated.
Oww!
Okay, okay!
- I'm strong.
- I had fun.
It was uncomfortable at times,
and a little frightening, but...
- Was it consensual?
- It was.
- Right.
Exactly, so that's what it's all about.
- [in unison] Thank you,
Mistress, may I have another?
(floggers cracking)
(men exclaiming)
- [director] Cut, cut, cut there!
- Wait, can I say I'm kinky now?
- Yeah!
- Hey, guys, I'm kinky!
(Mistress Hudsy laugh)
Hey, guys, I'm kinky.
Thanks for watching.